[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
[Jubel] Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Ich sag’s euch gleich: Heute geht es länger als 5 Minuten.
Nicht, weil ich viel quatschen möchte,
sondern das Rezept ist etwas ganz, ganz Besonderes.
Und zwar machen wir heute Iskender Kebap.
Der Iskender Efendi hat es erfunden.
Er kommt aus Bursa – das ist im Nordwesten der Türkei,
ist eine 3 Millionen-Stadt; ungefähr so groß wie Berlin,
am Fuße des Uludağ – ein 2.500m hoher Berg.
Die Stadt ist bekannt für seine Handtücher,
weil es ist neben Denizli fast das Zentrum der Textile in der Türkei.
Bursa ist bekannt für seine Oliven.
Auf dem Berg ist sowas wie Ischgl.
Uludağ ist die Schneeregion der Türkei.
Da sind dann die ganzen türkischen Rich Kids
und machen da ihre Winterferien.
Ich war da noch nie.
Ich war in Bursa; ich war nicht auf dem Berg.
Ich war unten und habe da wie normale Menschen Oliven gepflückt.
Wie gesagt, Oliven sind da auch sehr bekannt.
Heute machen wir ein bekanntes Gericht: Wie gesagt, Iskender Kebap.
Kebap ist ein allgemeiner Begriff für Fleisch.
Also alle Fleischgerichte werden Kebap genannt.
Dann gibt es natürlich Döner Kebap,
d. h. drehender Spieß, also drehender Fleischspieß.
Das ist Iskender. Iskender ist bekannt;
ihr bekommt es in jedem Dönerladen hier in Deutschland.
In der Türkei ist es auch sehr bekannt.
Da gibt es richtige Ketten. Die heißen Iskender Efendi.
Es ist sowas wie z. B. Hans im Glück bei uns.
Dieses Rezept machen wir heute.
Wir machen es auch traditionell.
Traditionell ist es ein bisschen schwer zu machen,
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, weil wir keinen Drehspieß haben.
Ihr braucht nicht denken, dass jeder Türke ein Drehspieß daheim hat,
weil Döner immer mit der Türkei in Verbindung gebracht wird.
Deswegen wird es ein bisschen tricky.
Es gibt verschiedene Zubereitungsvarianten von Iskender Kebap.
Manche machen es so als Gulaschscheiben.
Manche machen es als Dönerfleisch.
Manche kaufen den Döner fertig.
Aber wir kaufen ihn nicht fertig, sondern machen den Döner selber.
Deswegen habe ich hier ein paar Zutaten.
Wir würden jetzt mit dem Fleisch anfangen.
Hier haben wir beim Metzger unseres Vertrauens Rouladen geholt.
Rouladen ist entweder aus der Ober- und Unterkeule oder vom Bug.
Alles außer Filet, weil Filet sehr teuer ist.
Wie gesagt, da könnt ihr zum Metzger gehen
und einfach sagen „Ich brauche Roulade“.
Wir haben hier 1200 g, also 1,2 kg. Das ist ungefähr für 6 Personen.
Bei Iskender rechnet ihr eigentlich aus:
100-150g/Person, wenn es gute Esser sind.
Wie gesagt, heute kommen 6 Personen zu Besuch.
Nein, eigentlich kommt keiner zu Besuch. Macht das nicht!
Ich und die Kinder sind 4, Oma und Opa sind 6. Perfekt!
Ich, Ela, Samira, Sally, Oma, Opa = 6.
Genau! [Gelächter] 6 Personen. Perfekt!
In der App könnt ihr es übrigens auch auf 2 Personen runterrechnen.
Das Rezept ist eigentlich nicht so lang,
aber es ist eine Kunst, muss man sagen.
Ich würde jetzt gleich damit anfangen.
Wie gesagt, 1200 g Rouladenfleisch,
90 g Olivenöl – gutes Olivenöl natürlich von uns -,
2,5 TL Salz – keine Ahnung, woher dieses Salz kommt -,
3 TL getrockneten Thymian, 3 TL Paprika edelsüß, 3 TL Pfeffer,
3 weiße Zwiebeln - ihr könnt auch rote Zwiebeln nehmen.
Tut euch da wirklich nicht schwer. Nehmt das, was ihr zu Hause habt:
rot, grün, blau – egal, was für Zwiebeln!
[Doing] Nur schimmelig sollten sie nicht sein.
Dann haben wir noch aus unserem Garten frischen Thymian.
Den werden wir nachher auch noch dazu geben.
So, das sind die Zutaten für den [Modem Geräusche]
Döner, für das Fleisch oder für den Kebap. Nennt es, wie ihr es wollt.
Wollen wir mit dem Fleisch anfangen. Ich zeige euch, wie das geht.
Also fangen wir an. Das Fleisch muss mariniert werden.
Da machen wir eine ganz besondere Sauce.
Jetzt könnt ihr daheim einen Mixer nehmen oder
- bei uns ist der Mixer pink, deswegen wollte ich ihn nicht nehmen –
[Werbemusik] den 3600 Pro von Gefu Speedwing.
Da tu ich gleich – krasses Ding, oder? Ich lieb das Ding einfach!
Wenn ich mal sterben sollte, legt mir bitte das Ding ins Grab, ok?
Ist das in Ordnung? Könnt ihr machen.
Dann tun wir die Zwiebeln rein.
Ich übertreibe es jetzt mal nicht. Zack.
[Musik]
So, jetzt tu ich die anderen auch noch rein.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr daheim einen Mixer habt, macht sie da rein.
Ich brauche so ein richtig feines Püree.
So schnell kannst du keine Zwiebeln schneiden, gell?
Und du machst natürlich hier – seht ihr diesen Oberarm?
Jetzt wisst ihr auch, wo diese...
Dieses Gerät ist eigentlich nachgeahmt.
Ihr kennt doch in China diese Katzen, die immer so winken. Genau.
Wir haben auch eine Katze. Gib mal her!
So. Guck mal hin. So wurde das Gerät übrigens erfunden.
Jetzt habe ich gemerkt, ich drehe es durch.
Jetzt habe ich hier eine richtig coole,
ganz fein gehackte, püreeähnliche Masse.
Jetzt mache ich noch Folgendes.
Jetzt mache ich einen auf Jamie Oliver.
So, alles mit den Händen. Ich mache einen auf Jumbo.
Mach ich nicht! Natürlich nicht.
So, jetzt tun wir das Salz rein, den Thymian, Paprika edelsüß,
das Olivenöl – so! Und natürlich... wieso weine ich jetzt?
Habe ich mir in die Augen gelangt? [Traurige Klaviermusik]
Wie gesagt, macht wirklich nach Geschmack Pfeffer rein.
Ich mag sehr grünen, roten und schwarzen Pfeffer gleichmäßig.
[Traurige Klaviermusik] So, jetzt geht’s weiter.
Jetzt wieder vermischen.
Perfekt! Seht ihr?
Mmh! Das riecht jetzt nach [Doing] Zwiebelmasse. [Gelächter]
Könnt ihr übrigens einfach in die Spülmaschine legen.
Jetzt habe ich hier diese Zwiebelmasse.
Wie gesagt, nach Geschmack könnt ihr Sachen dazu geben.
Was ich jetzt vergessen habe, ist mir gerade eingefallen:
Ich habe den Thymian vergessen. Beim Thymian die Blätter –
frischen Thymian – gibt nochmal extra Ding.
So, das rühre ich jetzt noch mit hinein.
Was macht denn diese hier? Weg! Genau.
Jetzt kommt die Tricky-Variante.
Das heißt, wenn ihr daheim keine Zeit habt, könnt ihr wirklich
fertigen Döner entweder beim Dönerlieferanten oder beim Dönermann
holen oder ihr holt natürlich den Dönermann, genau.
Holt bitte keinen Döner aus der Gefriertruhe.
Das gibt es inzwischen in den Supermärkten auch.
Ich finde es richtig ekelig. Macht das bitte nicht.
Wer das macht, der wirft auch Hundewelpen ins kalte Wasser.
Deswegen machen wir einen coolen Trick.
Wir nehmen hier die Roulade. Ich zeige euch, wie das geht.
Ganz wichtig davor: Hände waschen,
weil nicht, dass die Pandemie ausbricht [Geschreie].
Kennt ihr das Holzbrett in Wuhan?
Auf jeden Fall haben wir hier das Fleisch.
Ich hätte auch eines machen können: Ich hätte alles in eine
Glasschüssel geben und dann leicht Jamie Oliver mit den Händen
da ein bisschen herumrühren können.
Es sieht für mich ein bisschen unappetitlich aus.
Kochen ist ja auch ein bisschen Kunst.
Wir möchten ja tolle Filmchen machen.
Deswegen mache ich die German Variante.
Ich gehe auf Nummer sicher, habe dann überall Sagrotan hingesprüht.
Nehme einfach hier das Ding und schmiere es drauf.
Seht ihr das? Das ist sieht doch jetzt edel aus.
Das sieht viel cooler aus,
als wenn ich mit meinen behaarten Wurstfingern da jetzt herumrühre.
[Musik]
Jetzt steigen natürlich die Aerosole auf
und ich kann kaum noch was sehen.
Jetzt kommt der Trick, und zwar Folgendes:
Jetzt habt ihr das Fleischstück hingemacht. Jetzt tun wir versetzt...
Ich zeige euch nachher, warum wir ihr das machen müsst.
Macht es einfach!
So ein bisschen versetzt.
Dann immer wieder das Ding und wieder einschmieren.
[Musik]
Durch das Versetzen habe ich jetzt eine größere Fläche gemacht,
weil ich das jetzt zusammenrollen möchte.
Daher kommt auch der Name.
Wenn ihr mal zu einem Dönerladen geht und da steht dann drunter:
Drehspieß oder Scheibenfleisch.
Also Döner darfst du eigentlich nur einen Spieß nennen,
der geschichtet ist. Das andere ist einfach nur ein Hackfleischspieß.
Geht mal wirklich in einen Dönerladen und fragt:
Ist es ein Hackfleischspieß oder ist es Scheibenfleisch?
Scheibenfleisch ist viel, viel teurer. Das ist jetzt Scheibenfleisch.
Das findest du leider Gottes kaum in Deutschland.
In der Türkei findest du kaum Hackfleischspieße,
aber in Deutschland ist es so, hauptsächlich, zu fast 95 %
sind es Hackfleischspieße und kein Scheibenfleisch.
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen eine größere Fläche gemacht.
Da gibt es einen Spruch: Faul darf es sein, aber nicht dumm.
[Doing] Hat mein Auszubildender, mein Meister immer zu mir gesagt.
Jetzt nehmen wir das Fleisch, ohne die Hände dreckig zu machen.
Also wir machen keinen Jamie Oliver Move, sondern wir tun das jetzt...
Habt ihr das gesehen? Oh, wie schön sauber!
Josh, hast du das gesehen?
Sieht man das, wie toll ich das gemacht habe?
Jetzt rolle ich das so zusammen.
[Musik]
Okay, jetzt habe ich doch einen Jamie Oliver Move daraus gemacht.
Schön einmassieren.
Genau, jetzt können wir außen noch ein bisschen draufschmieren.
So, jetzt zeige ich euch als Nächstes... kurz die Hände waschen!
[Musik]
Jetzt rollen wir das mit dem Backpapier so richtig schön ein
und machen einen Bonbon daraus.
Jetzt habt ihr so einen kleinen Habibi Grillspieß.
Jetzt legen wir dieses Ding 2 Stunden in die Gefriere.
Und zwar mache ich das,
weil ich nachher schöne Scheiben schneiden möchte.
Wir haben ja keinen vertikalen Drehspieß. Richtig?
Nein, vertikal ist so, horizontal ist so – Horizont oben, so!
Wir haben keinen horizontalen Grillspieß.
Ihr lernt auch Physik von mir!
Deswegen will ich, dass das Fleisch richtig hart ist zum Schneiden,
dass ich nachher schön, wenn es gefroren ist,
in Scheiben schneiden kann – mindestens 2 Stunden in die Gefriere.
Nicht in den Kühlschrank. Das bringt euch gar nichts!
Da könnt ihr auch... sage ich lieber nicht.
Einfach in die Gefriere.
[Uhr]
So, ich habe gerade geschaut.
Das Fleisch ist noch nicht ganz gefroren.
Das ist zwar ein bisschen Ding,
aber ich lasse es noch ein bisschen drin.
Während dieser Wartezeit – 15 Min. im Gefrierfach-,
mache ich schon einmal die Tomatensauce.
Die Tomatensauce ist ja ganz ausschlaggebend für Iskender Kebap,
weil das wird nachher über das Brot gegeben.
Deswegen habe ich hier 500 g passierte Tomaten, 50 g Tomatenmark
- am besten dreifach konzentriert -,
20 g Olivenöl, 1 TL Zucker, Salz und Pfeffer.
Jetzt müsst ihr ganz genau zuhören. Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig:
Jetzt nehmen wir einen kleinen Topf,
wo wir die Tomatensauce zubereiten.
Wir nehmen zuerst das Olivenöl, geben es hinein.
Dann nehmen wir das dreifach konzentrierte Tomatenmark
und geben es dazu, zack, und rösten es ein bisschen an.
Da gehen wir schon einmal auf – wir haben 10 Stufen im Herd – Stufe 6/7,
dass es kurz richtig warm wird,
weil ich möchte ja ein bisschen anrösten.
Jetzt kommt ein kleiner Trick – ist ganz, ganz cool:
und zwar ein bisschen Zucker. Dieser karamellisiert jetzt,
gibt noch einmal eine ganz coole Geschmacksnote.
Also, wie gesagt, nur 1 TL – auch mit rein und kurz erhitzen.
[Musik]
Ihr hört es auch kurz. Richtig schon ankokeln lassen,
also nur ganz leicht, damit diese Röstaromen
– ich rieche ich auch schon das Olivenöl mit dem Tomatenmark. Wow!
Jetzt einfach hier mit den passierten Tomaten mit 1/2 Liter ablöschen.
Schon ein riesen Vorteil, wenn du das nicht mit dem Holzlöffel machst,
sondern mit dem Silikonlöffel, weil da kriegst du noch alles heraus.
Schön jetzt ein bisschen köcheln lassen auf mittlerer Stufe.
Was ihr jetzt noch machen könnt, ist Folgendes
- das macht ihr aber nach Geschmack:
Noch ein bisschen Salz und Pfeffer rein.
Umrühren!
Jetzt kommt es auch darauf an. Ich mag z. B. die ganzen Speisen...
Geschmack verändert sich nach der Temperatur.
Also ich mag das, wenn alle Zutaten, die nach dem Iskender da sind,
auch warm sind – bis auf den Joghurt; dieser kann ruhig kalt sein.
Aber gerade die Tomatensauce sollte warm sein.
Jetzt rühre ich ein bisschen um. Wisst ihr, was ich gemacht habe?
Ich habe schon den Backofen vorgeheizt
und werde das jetzt einfach in den Backofen reinstellen.
Wenn ich später die Sauce darüber gebe,
ist sie richtig schön warm oder heiß.
Das ist kein Problem bei diesem Topf - ist ja ein Metallgriff.
Da kann nichts passieren.
So, jetzt nehme ich das – genau, ist heiß – und rein.
Jetzt tun wir es bei 150°C nochmal rein.
Was ich auch mache:
Nachher serviere ich das in diesem Gusseisenschiffchen.
Das muss auch warm sein, d. h., wenn ich nachher die Zutaten reinmache
und die Butter muss nachher noch richtig zischen.
Das mache ich auch rein – 150°C, gar kein Problem!
Unsere Schiffchen könnt ihr auch auf dem Grill nutzen.
Wir überbacken damit immer Käse.
Zwei, perfekt! Jetzt machen wir weiter mit der Joghurtsauce.
So, also wie gesagt, Fleisch in der Gefriere, die Tomatensauce im Backofen.
Jetzt machen wir das, was den Iskender zum Iskender macht,
die Joghurtsauce, außer der Tomatensauce.
Die Joghurtsauce, ganz wichtig – wir nehmen einen 10 %-igen Joghurt.
Ich nehme den Gazi; den nehmen wir immer.
Der ist wirklich genial. Hier ist es wichtig: 10 %!
Fett ist ein Geschmacksträger und 10 % Gazi schmeckt einfach anders.
Dann haben wir hier, wie gesagt, 1/2 kg.
Das andere 1/2 kg habe ich mir schon vorhin reingepfiffen.
1/2 kg haben wir hier drin.
Dann haben wir hier Minze – auch ganz cool,
einfach nur die Blätter nehmen, kurz abrupfen: Zack, zack.
[Musik]
Damit das Minzöl so richtig austritt, nehmen wir sie kurz in die Hand
und hauen richtig drauf, und nochmal! Wow!
Dann nehmt ihr das Murat Knife.
[Musik]
Hast du gesehen? Wie so ein japanischer Sushi-Koch, Josh.
Wir machen Folgendes: Jetzt machen wir das rein.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch Knoblauch.
Das ist wirklich nach Geschmack, also es mag nicht jeder.
Ich mag es unheimlich, wenn Knoblauch drin ist.
Mit dieser Presse müsst ihr den Knoblauch nicht schälen.
Einfach hier rein. So, jetzt passt mal auf.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir Knoblauch auch hier drin.
Jetzt verrühre ich es schon einmal ein bisschen.
Boah, ich liebe den Geruch einfach.
Dann ein bisschen Salz, Pfeffer – einfach darin schön verrühren.
Übrigens diese Eimer nachher nicht wegschmeißen; auswaschen!
Ich benutze sie in der Werkstatt für Schrauben und anderes Zeug
oder auch als Farbeimer.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr merkt,
die Sauce ist jetzt fast schon ein bisschen zu dickflüssig,
macht ihr folgenden Trick – keine Mengenangabe:
Einfach so ein bisschen Freestyle. Macht ein bisschen Wasser rein.
Zack. Genau, dass die Sauce ein bisschen flüssiger ist.
Nicht zu viel, aber ich möchte, dass es schön drüber läuft
und nicht in Klumpen ist.
Ein bisschen abschmecken.
Noch ein bisschen Salz und Pfeffer.
Wie gesagt, Knoblauch ist hier reine Geschmackssache.
Ich weiß, ich habe heute Abend noch etwas vor.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe noch ein Date, aber kein Date,
sondern ich habe heute Abend noch etwas vor,
aber das kannst du jetzt vergessen.
Wenn ich jetzt Zuschauer wäre,
würde ich den gleichen Löffel verwenden, aber ich mach es nicht.
[Trommelwirbel]
Mmh! Hammer! Oh, ich liebe es einfach.
So, jetzt haben wir beide Saucen gemacht.
Die Joghurtsauce kann jetzt einfach weg,
müssen wir gar nicht mehr kühlen – stellen wir beiseite.
Jetzt hole ich das Fleisch, schneide es auseinander,
mache daraus einen richtigen Dönerspieß,
aber nicht horizontal, sondern vertikal.
Es hat 2 Stunden gekühlt. Ihr könnt es auch über Nacht machen.
Ich würde sogar empfehlen, 3-4 Stunden zu kühlen,
dass es richtig hart ist,
weil dann könnt ihr es gefroren besser schneiden.
Aber ich habe keine Zeit,
deswegen ist es nach 2 Stunden schon so weit.
Dann fällt es beim Schneiden auch nicht zusammen.
Es geht dadurch wirklich einfacher. Jetzt schneide ich meinen Döner.
Natürlich hat Murat wieder alle Klischees erfüllt:
[Orientalische Musik] Teppichverkäufer, Gemüsehändler und Dönerschneider.
Boah, das riecht auch hammermäßig.
Das riecht wirklich wie, als wäre ich direkt am Dönerspieß dran.
Das Messer natürlich geht durch das Ding durch
wie ein heißes Messer durch die Butter.
[Musik]
[Doing] Toller wäre es, wenn ihr es mit dem Handschuh macht.
Mir ist gerade die linke Hand eingefroren.
Aua! Ich habe es schon gespürt. Dann wäre es Fingerfood gewesen
[Tusch]
Wow, über 1 kg Döner geschnitten.
Das riecht wie Döner. Das ist Döner.
So, jetzt haben wir es geschnitten. Jetzt tut mir einen Gefallen.
Jetzt braten wir das Ganze mit Butterschmalz an.
Ich mag einfach den Geschmack von Butter extrem.
In der Türkei würde ich jetzt Tereyağ nehmen.
Da könnt ihr ruhig viel nehmen.
Keine Ahnung, wo das Ding gerade herkommt.
Ich habe es aus dem Kühlschrank herausgeholt. Boah!
Das ist eine Riesen Gusseisenpfanne.
Die verwenden wir auch auf dem Grill oder für Aufläufe im Backofen.
Da könnt ihr auch ruhig... Macht der Pfanne nichts aus!
Schön hochheizen, die Pfanne. Jetzt holen wir uns eine Zange.
Haben wir eine männliche Zange hier im Haus?
Edelstahl? Von mir aus auch rostig?
Nur die hier? Ah, okay! Alles klar.
Jetzt braten wir es an, warten, dass die Pfanne richtig heiß wird.
Ungefähr 142°C, weil ab 140°C fängt die Maillard-Reaktion an.
Das heißt, Fleisch fängt an Röstaromen zu erzeugen.
JOSH: Biene Maja.
MURAT: [Doing] Ja, wie Biene Maja.
JOSH: Du hast doch gesagt: Maja-Reaktion.
MURAT: MAILLARD-Reaktion!
JOSH: Maillard?
MURAT: Ja!
Du hörst es jetzt auch. Hörst du es? Wahnsinn!
Man merkt, dass die Pfanne richtig heiß ist,
wenn man ein Stückchen Fleisch reinlegt
und man dann Blasen sieht, im Fett – seht ihr?
Hmm, es ist noch nicht ganz so weit.
Jetzt seht ihr auch, das dampft schon.
Jetzt mache ich das Fleisch rein.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt nur die Hälfte reingemacht. Jetzt ist ganz wichtig:
Ihr rührt jetzt nicht dauernd rum, das ist kein Rührteig!
Einfach richtig schön ankokeln lassen, richtig anbraten lassen
und dann nur einmal wenden und dann sofort raus,
und zwar in eine Emaille-Schüssel oder in irgendetwas,
das ihr nachher auch in den Backofen zum Warmhalten geben könnt.
Kurz warten, dass es richtig schön ein bisschen ankokelt,
ein bisschen Röstaromen kriegt und dann nur einmal wenden.
Das reicht schon. Wenn das Fleisch ein bisschen rosa ist,
nicht schlimm, wirklich nicht,
weil ich schiebe es nachher in den Backofen. Das gart nochmal nach.
Ich habe gesagt, nur einmal umdrehen, kurz reinpacken, so!
[Musik und Bratgeräusche]
Jetzt hole ich es heraus.
Ihr seht, daheim Döner machen ist gar nicht so einfach,
wenn man keinen Drehspieß hat.
Jetzt noch den Rest. Ihr kennt ja den Spruch:
Wer einem einen Döner brät, der braucht ein Dönerbratgerät.
[Tusch und Gelächter]
Aber kenne jetzt einige inzwischen,
die haben eine Dönermaschine – die kostet 200-300 € - zu Hause.
So, erstmal schön anbraten lassen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich alles raus. Den Herd einfach ausmachen.
Wir lassen aber diese Pfanne hier,
weil damit machen wir gleich was richtig Krasses.
Das Fleisch schieben wir in den Backofen rein, damit es nachgart.
Das heißt, das Fleisch nicht komplett durchbraten.
Ihr tötet es sonst wahrscheinlich zum 2. Mal.
Deswegen ganz cool, kann ein bisschen rosa und nicht ganz durch sein.
Gar nicht schlimm, weil wir es in den Backofen schieben.
Da ist es auch nochmal mind. 10-15 Minuten drin und kann nachgaren.
Diese Pfanne auf keinen Fall saubermachen.
Jetzt kommt was richtig Cooles.
Meine Frau hat vor 2 Tagen Ramazan Pide gemacht,
eine ganz normale Pide. Gerade zur Ramadanzeit wird es gemacht.
Da hat sie noch ein ganzes Blech übrig, und zwar das hier.
Guckt mal bei ihren Rezepten. Richtig cooles Pide,
schmeckt eigentlich erst dann richtig cool, wenn es frisch ist.
Nach 2 Tagen schmeckt es nicht mehr, aber ich wusste,
dass ich Iskender mache.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Pide heraus.
Wenn ihr daheim keine Pide oder Fladenbrot habt,
dann könnt ihr auch ein normales Brot nehmen.
Könnt ihr auch machen, gar kein Thema.
Ihr müsst es jetzt in Würfel schneiden.
Ich werde, weil es ziemlich weit aufgegangen ist,
hier in der Mitte komplett durchschneiden
und mache dann kleine Würfelchen daraus.
Das Krasse ist, ich muss dann nicht mehr schneiden.
Ich drücke das Ding einfach runter.
Kleine Würfel.
[Musik]
Ich habe euch gesagt, rührt die Pfanne nicht an!
Mit dem ganzen angekokelten Zeug drin
tun wir nochmal Butterschmalz drauf oder rein.
Ihr seht, es ist ein sehr buttriges Rezept,
aber es ist einfach ein Hammer Geschmacksträger.
Also wenn ihr gerade eine Diät macht, ist es nichts für euch,
aber wenn ihr einen Hammer Geschmack haben möchtet,
ist es kein Problem.
Das, was ich jetzt mache, kennt ihr auch aus der deutschen Küche,
und zwar einfach Croutons: Brot nochmal, wie soll ich sagen...
wie frittieren, dass Butterschmalz schön ins Brot übergeht.
Das Brot muss richtig knusprig werden.
Richtig schön heiß werden lassen.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehmen wir das Brot und geben es hinein.
Das sind solche Düfte! Echt! Leider gibt’s kein Geruchs-YouTube,
sonst würdet ihr das richtig toll riechen können.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn! Ich liebe einfach diesen Geruch.
Das reicht jetzt erst einmal.
Wenn ihr nicht so eine große Pfanne habt,
macht es in der kleinen Pfanne im kleinen Rahmen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich mache es gerade für 6 Personen.
Da ist es gerade groß genug.
Mein Gott, das kostet ja nichts! Öl drüber, fertig.
Ich liebe es einfach!
[Musik]
Ein kleiner Geheimtipp, damit es das besser aufnimmt:
Noch ein bisschen Wasser drüber.
[Musik]
Irgendetwas habe ich nicht richtig hingekriegt,
weil ich will es ja knusprig haben, aber sie sind weich geworden.
Kannst du ganz kurz helfen? Mein Gott!
[Jubel] Ist man auf die Frau angewiesen.
Ich wollte die Dinger knusprig haben, okay?
SALLY: Was hast du getan?
MURAT: Ich habe sie in Schmalz angebraten und dann habe ich gedacht,
ich gebe noch ein Schluss Wasser hinein, damit es so Wusch macht.
[Aufschrei]
SALLY: Wasser? [Murat bejaht]
Aber die sollen doch trocken und knusprig werden.
MURAT: Ja, das war ein Denkfehler.
Da habe ich in Physik nicht aufgepasst.
SALLY: Warum machst du das nicht im Backofen?
Einfach bei Heißluft?
MURAT: Heißluft Backofen oder Umluft?
SALLY: Heißluftgrill.
MURAT: Okay.
SALLY: Aber auf 2 Bleche aufgeteilt,
weil so werden sie auch nicht knusprig.
MURAT: Okay. Das heißt, nochmal 2 Bleche? [Sally bejaht]
Okay. Das heißt, daheim gebt ihr es einfach in kleinere Pfannen hinein
und schiebt es in den Backofen, richtig?
Man, man, man, man! Echt!
SALLY: Einfach so wie bei Croutons. Einfach die Brote mit Öl
und Butter auf 2-3 Ebenen im Ofen mit Heißluft rein.
MURAT: Auf wieviel Grad?
SALLY: 220°C.
MURAT: 220°C. Okay, dann mach ich das kurz Sally, okay?
Ich könnte auch hier die zwei aufteilen
und dann beide in den Backofen rein, oder?
SALLY: Der passt nur ganz unten rein.
MURAT: Oh, okay. Dann nehme ich lieber...
Danke schön!
Weißt du was? Ich mache kurz den Jamie Oliver Move, okay?
SALLY: Ja, komm! Hau rein!
MURAT: Ich mache kurz den Jamie, weil es wird ja eh jetzt heiß.
Ich will ja schon, dass es nachher richtig gut schmeckt.
Wenn man einen Fehler macht, sollte man es auch zugeben.
Das ist ja eigentlich wie ein Live-Video.
Ich schneide nichts raus, weil ich zeige die Fehler meiner Frau.
Nächstes Mal hörst du auf mich!
SALLY: Mein Fehler war, dass ich...
MURAT: Sei ruhig! Löscht das, ich sag’s euch!
Jetzt tu ich das in den Backofen
– Umluftgrill, damit es richtig schön kross wird.
[Musik]
Das auch noch oben rein – Umluftgrill. Zack!
220°C ungefähr 10 Minuten.
[Musik und Uhr]
Die Pfanne immer noch nicht sauber machen.
Ich habe hier noch Peperonis. Diese sind dunkelgrün.
Ich glaube, die sind auch scharf.
Da gibt es die hellgrünen.
Ich glaube, die heißen Charleston oder irgendwie sowas.
Jeder Türke kennt sie.
Die gibt es im türkischen Markt oder auch beim Lidl.
Die gebe ich einfach rein, ohne Fett.
Ich möchte sie ja ein bisschen angrillen,
dass sie etwas schwarz werden. Dann bekommen sie ein besonderes Aroma.
Jetzt habe ich gerade etwas vergessen.
Bevor ihr sie in die Pfanne reinwerft, müsst ihr Löcher reinmachen.
Einfach kurz mit der Gabel. Ansonsten platzen sie nachher auf,
wenn ihr sie z. B. schneidet, spritzt euch das Ganze ins Gesicht.
Wie bei der Wurst eigentlich, dass die Flüssigkeit entweichen kann.
Hier ganz cool – kurz ankokeln,
weil das ist auch typisch für Iskender,
dass neben dem Fleischgericht und den Broten
noch angekokelte Peperonis und Tomaten sind.
Meistens nimmt man die großen Tomaten,
aber ich habe hier Cocktailtomaten genommen.
Diese waren gerade im Angebot.
Wisst ihr was, den lasse ich gerade dran. Zack!
[Musik]
Das riecht jetzt so richtig wie gegrillt
– die ganzen Tomaten und Peperonis.
Währenddessen nehme ich ein bisschen Butter,
gebe sie in einen kleinen Topf rein und schmelze sie kurz.
Dann kommt nochmal Paprika edelsüß rein.
Hier kocht gerade die Butter auf.
Jetzt gebe ich Paprika edelsüß in die Butter.
Die Butter muss so richtig heiß werden.
Ihr merkt das daran, dass sich oben ein Schaum bildet.
Was ich auch noch dazu gebe, was ich liebe:
Ihr könnt jetzt nochmal Chiliflocken nehmen,
weil das ist die Krönung am Schluss über das Fleisch,
über den Joghurt drüber, alles nochmal davon hier.
Und ein bisschen Chiliöl, damit es ein bisschen scharf wird.
Jetzt fängt die Zeremonie an.
Das ist jetzt wie bei den Japanern die Teezeremonie
- fängt jetzt bei Iskender Murat die Iskender-Zeremonie an.
Was brauchen wir als allererstes?
Als allererstes brauchen wir unsere Formen.
Die sind hier drin.
Einmal. Zweimal.
Jetzt müsst ihr euch vorstellen:
Meine Freunde, wenn ich welche hätte [traurige Musik],
würden jetzt am Tisch auf mich warten und es würde hier hammermäßig
nach Fleisch, Peperoni und gegrillten Tomaten riechen.
Jetzt habe ich das. Als Nächstes kommt das Brot.
Jetzt haben wir das Brot. Jetzt können wir ganz kurz...
Macht das nicht, das ist richtig heiß, aber es ist knusprig.
Mmh! Hört ihr es?
Ihr hört es. Ich spüre es. Es ist ziemlich heiß.
Jetzt nehme ich einen Löffel.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich den Joghurt und gebe ihn darüber.
In der Türkei wird das direkt am Tisch gemacht.
Jetzt hole ich die Tomatensauce.
Oh mein Gott! Als ob ich das noch nie gemacht hätte.
Als Nächstes kommt das Fleisch [Heilige Musik]: Der Döner.
[Musik]
Jetzt ganz typisch noch hier jeweils eine Peperoni, schön angekokelt
und ein paar Tomaten. Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt Besuch
und legt dem Besuch so etwas hin. Der dreht ja total durch!
Es lohnt sich wirklich. Ihr braucht maximal dafür,
für die ganze Zubereitung, 1 Stunde,
für das Kühlen nochmal 2-3 Stunden.
Aber das könnt ihr einen Tag vorher machen.
Aber in 1 Stunde habt ihr das wirklich ganz easy hinbekommen.
Jetzt stellt euch vor, ihr seid am Tisch.
Alle haben den Mund offen und sagen:
Boah! Wow! Wie genial sieht das aus? Was hat der Murat hier wieder...
äh... [Doing] gezündet, wollte ich gerade sagen... gekocht!
Jetzt nehmen wir die Butter.
Guck mal, so muss die Butter aussehen, Josh. Guck mal rein!
Schaumig und richtig heiß!
[Musik]
So, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ich habe ein paar Freunde, die wollen jetzt doch nicht vor die Kamera.
Einen habe ich, der muss vor die Kamera, weil er arbeitet hier.
Und zwar der Holger, Tolga oder ja...
So Tolga. Probieren wir es einmal. [Jubel]
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Das Besondere an diesem Rezept ist wirklich nicht die Zubereitung.
Die ist wirklich total easy. Das Besondere an diesem Rezept ist,
dass man die richtigen Temperaturen zusammenbekommt
und dass es auch beim Essen richtig heiß ist.
Also hau mal rein! Probier' mal!
TOLGA: Sieht schon lecker aus.
MURAT: Sieht gut aus? [Tolga stimmt zu]
Pass auf, ich hole noch ein bisschen Salz.
Ich mag es noch ein bisschen nachzusalzen, automatisch,
obwohl ich es noch gar nicht probiert habe.
Es gibt Menschen, die salzen immer,
obwohl sie es nicht probiert haben. Ich gehöre dazu!
Boah! Jetzt mal ohne Witz! Das ist das beste...
Das ist wirklich. Also guck mal.
Ich habe echt schon Iskender überall gegessen.
Ich darf das nicht sagen, aber ich glaube, es ist das beste Iskender,
was ich jemals in meinem Leben gegessen habe.
TOLGA: Normalerweise esse ich kein Rindfleisch, aber...
Ey, das schmeckt richtig gut!
MURAT: Ist auch kein Rind; ist Schwein gewesen.
War ein Spaß! Aber cool, Hammer!
[Echo: Schwein gewesen]
Hammer! Boah! Jetzt mal ohne Spaß.
Wenn ihr Menschen wirklich voll beeindrucken möchtet,
dann macht das Ding nach.
TOLGA: Hast du die Brotstücke angebraten?
MURAT: Ja, angebraten und geröstet.
Da habe ich so einen besonderen Trick drauf.
Hammer, gell? Ich will gar so viel zu den Zuschauern reden.
Ich will einfach nur das Ding auch mal essen. Wahnsinn!
TOLGA: Ich auch! [Lacht]
MURAT: Mmh! Hammer!
TOLGA: Dürfen wir alles essen oder...?
MURAT: Nein.
[Hundebetteln]
Ich schmeiße es dann weg. Macht euch gar keine Sorgen.
Murat schmeißt solche Dinge sehr gern weg! Okay?
Auf jeden Fall hat es mir richtig Spaß gemacht.
Iskender war wirklich Deluxe!
War ein bisschen durcheinander, das ganze Video.
Das tut mir wirklich leid.
Bitte hatet nicht mich; hatet die anderen.
Da gibt es noch ein paar andere, die ihr haten könnt.
Macht das bei mir nicht!
Ihr könnt dem Kanal auch folgen
– ist nicht meiner; gehört meiner Frau.
Hat mir richtig Spaß gemacht.
Ich hocke mich jetzt hin und schmeiße das alles hier weg.
Ja, so... schmeiße es weg, okay?
Das war ein Witz. Hier, nimm das mit!
Also Tschüss, macht’s gut!
Hammer, wirklich! Brutal.
TOLGA: Das schmeckt richtig geil. [Murat stimmt zu]
[Musik]